breeding some podcast Vil its Thursday
the 19th of September get your [ __ ]
together the church is brought to you by
policy genius.com if you think of
insurance think of policy genius.com the
church is also brought to you by hems
calm listen you're starting to lose your
hair you're a little embarrassed you're
28 you don't know what's going on but
once you've noticed thinning hair it can
be too late
is that headline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yet listen
don't worry about it
for hems calm has you covered you're
like Joey what firms a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care and sexual wellness
for men do you understand me no snake
oil pills or gas station counter
supplements right now today the
listeners the church family can get
started with hymns with a complete hair
kit for just $5 you like Joey what are
you talking about I'm talking about $5
right now while supplies last and
subject to doctor's approval see website
for full details and safety information
this could cost you hundreds you know
this could cost you hundreds of hours if
you went to a doctor or a farmers you
somewhere else right I'm gonna save you
the aggravation in time go to forums
comm slash Joey again that's for hims
com
slash Joey oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
tell your bookie you're gonna [ __ ] them
in the ass this week you're going
[ __ ] three and all you're gonna
double up with a parlay yes it is it's
football season ladies and gentlemen and
there's also college football no fear
you know the holidays a couple months
away and you want to get the party
started
everybody wants to get that dick sucked
but you don't know where they get it but
when I get the party started all right I
know for the last three weeks she was
like saying oh yeah [ __ ] the wing ones
given 23 points this week at home to the
Jets are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
not gonna even think about that do you
think that New England can beat the [ __ ]
and spread this week
and make some Madhu you have a [ __ ]
crystal ball we're good go to my bookie
dad AG right now today
that's my bookie dad AG right now what
good is if you have the winners if you
don't [ __ ] make no money this year
they're running a super contest a halal
Center you pick five teams a week
against the spread and you rack up the
points first place is guaranteed a
hundred thousand [ __ ] dollars who's
better than you stop talking [ __ ] go to
my bookie doll AG today
that's my bookie doll AG and don't
forget to use promo code Church when
creating your account you like Joey what
account listen they're gonna double your
first deposit right now up to a thousand
[ __ ] dollars that means if you put in
a genome they give you a [ __ ] G note
who's better than you nobody go to my
bookie doll AG right now a promo code
Church you win you play you win you get
[ __ ] paid Lisa at take this
[ __ ] meal [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] nuts or what Dean there is e and
the house ask from [ __ ] shows TV
shows and touring bands [ __ ] Iron
Maiden on Saturday night
Elton John the week before this guy
lives like my gain a but you don't [ __ ]
around I'm saying he's out there 7 24 53
years old what's your [ __ ] excuse
[ __ ] I want you think I'm good man
it's great to be back good chef your
family man ah I was thinking about it
today I prayed music like 25 years and
and had some great friends but when I
think about the comedy family that I got
it's just insane
you know not love it I wake up every
morning and I go what the [ __ ] happened
and how did I get here and I think I'm
about 1994 you know doing all these
crazy [ __ ] open mics to them I forget
you know and then I go okay that's how I
got here yeah work or can you meet this
you meet these people along the way and
some of them dropped off and so I'm
stuck with it
and you're stuck with them they're your
family and yeah somebody called me today
and said I signed one of your friends
Maz Jobrani oh you don't understand he's
not my friend my ship Ronnie's my family
yeah my surprise would give me a 21 I
needed one never told nobody la mancha
brawny was my family my Gibran eat I got
me a commercial agent Maz Jobrani you
know well you know it's a shame when
people go out you get help from Joe
Rogan I got help from Joe Road and guess
who got me my first agent Ari Shaffir
guess who [ __ ] got me on his show
when comedy central wouldn't talk to me
Ari Shaffir yeah I'm saying - let me
tell the stories I did to grow everybody
helps you whenever people know you're
all in
they [ __ ] lend the helping hands
they'll start this dude's always as a
general [ __ ] there's one of us hills and
he's not appear to cannot sense about
directing or jumping out of a helicopter
he's here at 1:00 in the morning
grinding it out and that's you know when
the universe takes care you know say
you're fortunate also oh man - got an
education from bur Marc Maron you got 22
different education yeah you Rogan Ian
Edwards
you know all all the guys it's just it's
I didn't know how tight you were with
Ian yeah I talked to that [ __ ] every
day like you you know oh yeah I love him
by the way yeah and I think he's a very
underrated
I think he's deadly on stage I think
he's a brilliant writer yeah the
sweetest guy you'll ever meet
just the way he approaches you just a
combo of him and Rogan Rogan does not
like soccer people always thought that
me and Rogan were funny together yeah
they're funny and now they have a thing
going on who falls asleep yeah on the
plane I saw that mr. Rogan could fall
asleep I love him to death
yeah he's got something that none of us
have he could turn it off anywhere yeah
I did the same thing man you can yeah I
tell people you know like I'll meet
people in like a man I just can't sleep
and I'm like
if I stop moving for a minute I'll go to
sleep no problem no prob
he's sleepin coach because in first
class I can understand I sleep falsely
in coach like a [ __ ] demon like I
mean I'm out as soon as the wheels are
up oh I'm out a reason why you and me
can't sleep as coaches have you don't
fit yeah you can't when you sleep on a
tiny bed yeah I'm not gonna sleep you're
scared to fall asleep you're gonna fall
off yeah I got these new things Bose
sent me there you know they got the
noise cancelling headphones whatever
that these you pop them in there noise
cancelling and then you choose what
sound you want waterfalls raindrops
white noise anything and it's like the
beginning of me so holy like yeah Oh
sock it to me sock it to me they got it
they got a right they should make an app
where you could do your own sounds you
know it could be you like oh [ __ ] this
times I'm having a weird day and I would
just turn on me so horny
oh my 20 times just the other beginning
it makes me laugh my ass because that
was from something I saw as a child oh
yeah it was like a black porno right
right like in the 70s a sample to it
it's a sample yeah from a black porno
they'll all sock it to me like people
talk back back to me that [ __ ] to where
is that stuffing like baby's got back
remember that video sir mix-a-lot baby
got back you know no the video that
video was hilarious I still remember
taking me so horny yeah
he said yeah I went out bought yeah yeah
like all the cassette I did something
weird and I took it to a Chrysler
Plymouth dealer friends of mine there
yeah he was a Christian I always steal
his pens when he was cutting a deal
yeah I'd steal this bread parking pad
yeah he's like where's my red pocket
panting would go nuts so I had to
lighten up on the red parka pens for a
while so every time out of customer I
was like an old man I called him all the
guys like sittin at home with my dick
come on I got my black book for my freak
the cop and he would start looking
around like he couldn't he couldn't say
what the [ __ ] yeah for old people
yeah he would just look at art you know
I'd even go I don't know me so horny
yeah
we saw I love you and the old people
would be sitting there beating their
heads would not listen to the lyrics and
finally the old guy caught on and he's
like looking at his wife like and oh my
god I used to torture people with a saw
oh my god it's so funny when you're
selling [ __ ] how you can't break your
seller note no matter what's going on
I remember I was selling motorcycles and
I was looking at this screen of this
motorcycle video in the shop and then I
didn't think anyone is around I just
farted and the customer was right behind
man he goes Jesus because Jesus and my
boss is got garl fell on the ground
because you know when you're like you
forget where you're at you just fart
just before the fart never you can never
write a joke bigger than the fart
somebody farts somewhere it's so funny
to them it's and I love being onstage
and stopping me on either Shh
oh yeah oh then far
but don't hear it I'll pick up my leg
I fought in DC ah and the owner left I
blew fought on space that's it I'm
addict hey was he doing fart jokes
little Kasem I knew nothing in life
about counterterrorism ya know yeah
until I started selling cars yeah oh
yeah and then I became an expert on
counterterrorism like stealing the keys
out of the car when the sells was about
to sell it all that [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
blower salesman off so I have to cut you
with oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah oh my go
yeah was for you to have a nervous
breakdown
yeah like we robbed and oh god bless his
soul my go he sold too many [ __ ] cars
I couldn't keep up yeah and enough was
enough
I'm number one of this [ __ ]
jungle haha when it comes to being
number one you gotta play [ __ ] dirty
I was twenty [ __ ] something years oh
yeah you know I really dealership paid
10,000 a month I'm making thirty five at
this Chrysler plant but they close at
seven oh yeah you know there were a
white little fam comfortable no problem
here we are in this Norton kilos in the
showroom and I'm tormenting this kid I
mean there were days he just went home
yeah it wasn't bullying or nothing like
that
it was counterterrorism we're all here
trying to make a buck and I gotta take
the top guy off the top when did you
have time I actually sell cars because I
would talk to him subtly I wouldn't talk
I would go in there earlier and thought
my torture process I'd start like a trap
yeah and then I go out and sell cars
like nothing was happening oh my gosh
dominoes are falling like somebody would
come in and go hi I'm looking for robbed
and oh I would say robbers in the back
busy even though robbing the backi in
the bagel and I would give him to a
different sales oh oh that's the worst
now Rob would come out and see this and
his face we just turned beet red so
game would be off yeah so then he would
let the salesman sell the car he would
be pacing in the back like Akkad's down
and once the deal was done he would blow
up oh yeah it was my [ __ ] deal yeah
my name is Anand I guess I kind of know
Diaz game to me you know that was my
customer you know oh because once you do
that to somebody early they can't play
the game anymore
oh they're mad all day they're mad all
day you wiped him out but it all
counter-terrorism also works against you
sometimes because you're pissed on some
of these legs so you're making yourself
negative why you're pissing on
somebody's leg yeah that's why he's a
practice I just don't use anymore I
don't use it in comedy but I will use it
in life yeah my comrades in common yeah
well they go on stage come up to them to
say hey you're losing your hair you know
that's the last thing comic wants to
hear before they go on say yes put on a
little weight you put on a little walk
what the [ __ ] he can see the right to
see me oh that's what you do yeah you
know at the stall I could say somebody
had a big showcase of people and I found
out about it I hated you and let's say
with the showcase was at 9:30 I'd call
by so yeah and trust
that's loves all that oh [ __ ] make guys
go down and walking at 9:20 bomb oh my
god the back hello we just see out of
its face oh we call Eddie Griffin oh
make up three-hour and tell him to come
down early tonight there's gonna be
alive and kicking he go what's going on
man cuz and he was walking about a
quarter to ten I'd make them go down
there because all the showcases were at
9:15 yeah yeah so I'd have Eddie bump
Argus like you're not even going up to
that do three and I go up there behind
you and then he would stay on in the
comic would just be pasted in the back
and me and three other guys would be
Howlin because we knew what was going on
but that works against y'all yeah yeah
yeah karma kicks in you don't do it in
comedy but you could pay the people in
life you know like your landlord or
something like that you could piss on
his leg I
to me in common inside there are there
are never enemies it's like we're all
we're all their people at the store yeah
but I won't say throw them under the bus
cause I love them too much yeah they do
try to piss on my leg
ha ha ha before I go on stage yeah I
catch it and I giggle and I tap them on
the shoulder to let them know I'm happy
that they tried to use a Heather I was
doing that might one yeah yeah you
should be ashamed of yourself yeah thank
you for these yeah I got I got good for
you good for you yeah you try at least I
see you don't ya I ain't mad at ya it's
not either the Voodoo don't work on
uncle Joey I'd done that [ __ ] yeah yeah
are you like what you know it's just
something uh it's weird because why
you're talking about pissing on your leg
I really thought about the statement I
made you a couple weeks ago we're gonna
do a podcast today out of respect for
Ric Ocasek you know god bless his soul a
man being both like them but I was
telling Dean and Dean I've always been
dates with you like I've known areas of
concerts I've been always really good
there's 20 concerts I know I forgot
about oh yeah same here there's 20
conscious that I know that somebody has
to bring him up and I really got to
think and then I gotta call somebody to
collaborate exactly the cars were the
first concert I think I want to see that
that was the first time that I knew my
concert days are gonna be over oh I told
you know what I think there were at
Central Park yep and the sound wasn't
right right doors either could the cars
but nobody really knew till they got
there I think even the doors didn't know
how being outside affected them compared
to like being at the garden of the PO a
horse
jaysus know ambience yeah didn't I wind
I didn't see him on the on the can do
tour the first tour I was hip to those
out
same here I still remember the first one
hit Oh God the earth one hitting was
[ __ ] huge huge and then it being the
soundtrack of that movie last times yeah
I don't know I don't know how far
difference it was from the time Fast
Times came
yeah what the fast times come out and
when did that record came out if they
get 78 and fast times like 81 aware but
it really made it famous again you know
like so big but that whole record is
every songs a hit it's crazy to think
that they he was that good of a
songwriter Ric Ocasek
8282 fast times first record 78 but you
know it's such a pivotal scene in the
film you know that it's it just feels
like it came out that year you know you
gotta remember at that time it was Ted
Nugent yeah it was Black Sabbath it was
you know Judas Priest was alive and
kicking there were all these bands that
were little heavy him that we were
listening ac/dc a lot of us were
listening to punk you know a couple of
us like you know I like to class some of
their music there was a couple other
guys that black I don't know Devo Devo I
leg time I Devo it was a couple bands
I'd seen in the city that right now
slipped my mind again you know the years
of abuse and drugs but I still remember
getting there
I think the album yeah after the cause
and being blown away like this isn't
what we listened to so I'm gonna be
careful before I bring this out yeah you
know Ryan your friends I yeah yeah yeah
I'm gonna be a little careful this is
girl music yeah because it didn't really
have a job but they called a new wave
yeah but it was just like its own thing
it really was its own thing cuz new wave
was a little to me goofy and fun you
know you got like b-52s that was new
wave rock lobster you know that got
destroyed
yessum fell are not came killer that
album was played in every part on when
to why was the end of the night after
everybody got this Springsteen and their
priest fixed yeah somewhere slipped in
the b-52s totally and some tough guys
were still not dancing oh yeah yeah down
came out tough guys was still not
dancing no dancing no laughing once the
quaaludes came in and you had a dance if
you want to eat that monkey yeah you got
a dance the
hips against them put a heart of the
Weinstein deal you have no idea what
you're doing you're dancing if you've
never danced and you're just trying it
you're just doing something hit I like
this yeah I love the dancing early on by
the 8th grade at school dances yeah I
was already busting a move yeah I knew
that if you want to get anywhere with a
girl you got a dance tour if they got to
see your hips move I watch Soul Train
and I've chased like I was Don Cornelius
was a god to me dog i watch that show
every week I never miss no we grew up on
that American Bandstand loved it I mean
it was a different time
you know I always hear the argument that
there's nobody who promotes new bands
anymore you know what
I don't remember time when they were
promoting new bands either yeah if you
were good you [ __ ] slam if you didn't
you sack yeah that was it if you you
know I we grew up on Soul Train Saturday
afternoon I'm gonna have American
Bandstand Saturday afternoon where
college football never even thought a
canceling yeah yeah Bergen best and God
it's is [ __ ] that Clark always got
its in and then Saturday night we had
Don curses rock on smoking and I think
Friday night was the midnight special
our back to back yeah we Saturday Night
Live in to Don curses Rocco yep I cannot
tell you how many nights I stopped
partying to run home to see Donna curses
rock concert because somebody in
particular was gonna be huh and the man
that I remember the most running home
for was Black Sabbath Oh
oh man I still remember Donkers to bring
them up I still remember my dick being
hard I had tears in my eyes oh my god
about the [ __ ] see him this is uh
maybe here before they broke up you know
at 78th and maybe six months before the
[ __ ] damage was done oh how great was
that show Don Kirshner's rock cuts you
think about that now this [ __ ] would
never fly they get the biggest [ __ ]
bands the biggest bands that come down I
was talking to a guy that worked on it
they would shoot it during the day over
and uh you know I think Warner Brothers
Burbank or whatever
during the day they would shoot like
three bands in one day and you know
they'd have like a hundred people in the
audience and there they were just
rocking that wild biggest band ever not
one song like you know like on Fallon or
something now it would be like they'd
play three four songs all concert [ __ ]
crazy great and Soul Train they had the
Soul Train dancers Gaga and at the end
they did the the dance down the aisle
yeah but the guy left you always I still
know the episode when the microphone
fell and the guy kept singing oh [ __ ]
they're like sickening was there Michael
that was the first time I realized I was
like 7 or 8 yeah that lip-syncing he
even existed yeah like you're like with
the microphone it fell but the song kept
playing uh he was left on stage look on
his face Don Cornelius it was funny in
Edwards and I one day I posted a clip of
Don Cornelius on Instagram and I said
every Saturday I never missed the
episode and he texted me right-wingers
you used to watch that and I go Michael
religion man and then I found out later
the rock club that I booked the stone in
San Francisco early on was where they
first started shooting Soul Train years
before it was a rock club straight crazy
to think well I'm in the same building
as like Soul Train was filmed that was
shot up in the Bay Area for a while I
guess in him where were the rest I don't
know where the rest of them were but we
could find out on Wikipedia but that
[ __ ] was you know Bay Area first and it
was amazing that guy had a I think he
was a DJ at first Don Cornelius I did
really read up on it for a while and
then I'd forgot but I think he was a DJ
or something then had that show but he
was so badass how smooth was he being
all right his voice was trim I summon
the Barry White being on that yeah Elton
John Joey showed clips at the show there
was another white guy who was on there
that was Oh David Bowie Bowie was a
David Bowie who is on you and famed
miss Johnson yes yeah yeah yes he did
Fame the Brothers Johnson The O'Jays
you know I grew up on that that was
lakeside Earth Wind & Fire Oh Parliament
played on the Oliver wait oh you finally
yeah I'm just looking for a San
Francisco all Campanas la yeah yeah
started in Chicago actually Chicago and
then and then and then I'm pretty sure
it was filmed in San Fran for like two
years or something that's what I read
somewhere so who knows if it you know
when you're reading stuff you're like oh
cool you never check if it's the if it's
really like all right yeah I was there
but that's also Wikipedia yeah yeah but
supposedly it was filmed in that same
place that that became a famous rock
club wait or the stone pretty wild but
man I was watching Elton John and he was
showing old clips behind him and they
had the Soul Train clips and there is
man wearing like a green suit and the
glasses with the clear piano just
killing it on there I was Elton John he
was a youth leader
72 years old three hours crushing it no
opener and just murdered it I mean mark
comes out starts with Benny and the Jets
and never looks back
and it's crazy how Gradius got three
original guys in the band still the
drummer the guy that does the percussion
the older guy up there with the bongos
and the tambourine and then the guitar
player three guys it's been in since
like 71 I was Iron Maiden seven oh man
well that was just another level who
opened up for them Fozzie you know
what's his name's band the wrestler
what's name he has the podcast he's the
famous wrestler got him drawn a blank on
his name and then some other band I
missed but Burr and I went and it was in
saying there they're showing all the
other band
hey we spend all our money on the stage
show I think they are they're like we
got plenty of money let's put on a show
no one's [ __ ] sin every three songs
it's a different stage monsters
backdrops fire [ __ ] flies it's
experience they open with a [ __ ] b-52
plane flying over the stage huge plane
just flying over it's crazy
huge I was like what that's the opener
and Dickinson he's so bad as he's a yeah
we open with that that would be most
people's closure but no we [ __ ] open
and we get better bigger you know he's
like going crazy the crowd they played
the soccer stadium the new one I never
been there where the LA sport's arena
used to be they put a huge soccer
stadium there off that 110 there you can
see it [ __ ] places giad see [ __ ] I
think that thing holds like 50,000 video
it was GI was all the way to the top
four all the way to the top I mean they
were seen on the planet people are
really coming out to support the Arts
these days they are man I really gotta
have it's a little comedy to music you
know I mean there's still loyal people
after that they just love entertainment
I mean all these shows you know what's
what's kiss at the KISS Army the tour is
that [ __ ] breaking fire money records
that they just what the bank yeah they
just why heard any trunk said the figure
about two weeks ago where they're at so
far with tours I mean people are going
out people are actually paying money for
these tickets yeah and they're enjoying
themselves god bless them you know
monday there was a guy that called in to
Eddie trunk talking about uh ticket
prices now he stopped supporting love
especially G&R is is his point with Gina
right that were paying too much money to
go see G&R
do 30 year old songs now that's a they
respected the order of their fanbase
they would come out with a new album and
all this [ __ ] think I made some good
points he asked me in any trunk made
some great points also about you know
that that slash and Duff is still very
active and they put out solo projects in
between they've been successful but that
he feels that Axl Rose is such a greedy
[ __ ] that he won't you know he goes
he's weak so he wants to go told ac/dc
but he won't [ __ ] him put in a while why
don't we get the guys in the best studio
and let's get a new album why would I
want to pay a homage to go see [ __ ]
30 year old music and he felt that hi
and maiden was very good to their
fanbase
right he said I am Maiden as one of the
best angle I would try tickets they
don't let scalpers get their hands on
the tickets he goes that he was talking
about fan bases was very interesting
yeah really interesting about you know
and and he had told him and he trunk
told them at the end he goes you know
who stops these bands from doing this
you do yeah just jump hang around your
bugs and you want to pay a tea for a
beer and a hundred for a t-shirt just
don't go yep but the more you go the
more you go on to support this somebody
came up to me in San Antonio and said I
paid 300 house a piece for your tickets
I go don't ever do that I'm not worth
any more than that ticket price it's a
shame that you have all these [ __ ]
people take their ticket prices just to
make the exchange online
yeah $13 $3 for paper it breaks my heart
you know
don't pay over that I'm not [ __ ]
worth it yeah don't pay over there I'll
be back in sometime if you see I'm on a
schedule somewhere make a trip but don't
ever pay that money go to the [ __ ]
see the website people hit me up all the
time I'm not going to see you your
tickets are 311 now they're on the wrong
website what are you [ __ ] talking
about yeah where my the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] flyer and the [ __ ] website
connects you with the link to the
[ __ ] site yeah why are you on any
other [ __ ] side paying $311 and Joe
Diaz I don't get it are you [ __ ]
crazy you think
would charge you 300 and [ __ ] $11
without a gun yeah you know I'm saying
like just it's just people have no idea
what they're buying so you just gotta
watch what's of site you're going to you
know go to the direct [ __ ] if the stones
have died not the stone thing yeah hash
it out all those people just they don't
need to deal with it's right on our
website I always tell people they can't
when they come into Milwaukee it's like
it's all there man I mean I pay for this
website every month so you go it's the
easiest spot
Dean Delroy calm you know because if I
post it in Twitter and Instagram and
everything algorithms I post the link
yeah I post a link to have a [ __ ]
website I want you to go yeah so you say
[ __ ] money
there it is I mean I don't you know you
don't get a piece of ham but I want to
talk to you about some but the cause
real quick before I forget the cars
taught me a very can do be out yeah
taught me a very big lesson about what I
do today you know when you take pictures
of people you usually have little
conversations with them yeah you know
and some people come over when they
shake him you're 18
nice to meet you job he is and I put my
own their own they put my in their own
room they arm around me and as we're
taking the picture they'll say man I was
having a hard time letting to the
podcast thanks for helping me out and I
would go back to my hotel room you know
how [ __ ] creepy is that
yeah how creepy is that you know the
next one they talking about I couldn't
really handle that when people would say
that to me I was my my poor son died and
I listened to your podcast and they
really helped it sounds like that's
[ __ ] crazy and then one day I was
listening to can do hit me yeah can do
that album was Wally Elms that kept me
together after my mother died can do was
something I look forward to listening to
the whole out there's not a bad song
the Elliot Easton oh the guitar work on
there is [ __ ] just he's a little guy
that he's from Long Island and the car
was bigger than him
yeah the guitar was big in the heavy
matted yeah if you watch all these car
videos the guitars bigger than he is and
he just [ __ ] it up some of his leads a
[ __ ] nasty but can do if I think
about it is one of my top 10 albums
because it kept me together at a time
where I must listen to the album for the
first year and a half after my mother
died every day ma'am so now when people
say to me hey I listened to the podcast
I could relate I'm not saying I'm
because I just could relate to what they
were saying it helped me I loved all
that [ __ ] yeah when the other day when I
got my friend call me from Jersey and he
goes did you hear Ric Ocasek night when
I hung up I thought about you bumping
into him six months ago in the city and
a crazy and you say look great you'd hit
a crepe he's my neighbor
that's nuts and then I thought about
just being a kid listen to those first
two albums you're the first album I had
at the house before my mother died I
store my Malad Ted double live was
ruling the charts my ass double right on
so you had a bus through Ted Born to Run
yeah was born to run out already Born to
Run yeah yeah you had a bust out through
the kinks yeah and then you know with
all these bands that people go down
you're not putting the cars out of my
party
uh-huh like there were people that I
still remember visibly telling me we
don't play the cars in my house not even
my feeling is a beer I just go okay I
think you're missing out on a great
[ __ ] band I got the first down was
great and I thought the second round was
just spectacular like if you watch
people's work well not anymore
except for maybe the little skinny
blonde and Beyonce you you judge people
by I don't like judging specials
I don't like judge and see these yeah I
like to judge the whole library like I'm
I have a friend that calls into the
podcast we haven't had him calling over
a hard time
Frank Cannella Frankie know his father
was a jazz drummer we were growing up
and him and I were in a band together I
was the lead singer and all we did was
live sing yeah the Beatles
living room rock live a little rock yeah
find the bass player and the whole
[ __ ] being that my voice chains I
didn't sound like Michael Jackson yeah
[ __ ] show but I'm in shortly after
John Bonham died me being at his house
and his mother of all people said that
she goes you know I like him I like that
boy yeah yeah long that every album was
really really different and that showed
you the strength of who they were why
she didn't judge them as she's judging
us after she goes after Ellis Tom this
is before coda camera yeah it's gonna
yeah this before come on a big fan of
color all I can do the outdoor though
yeah in through the out door
I [ __ ] love Kyle it's a great love in
the evening aha I'm a mood my neighbors
with Jehovah Witnesses on given that
Terrace knocking on my door 7:30 in the
morning
Oh telling me the lower than my bedroom
because they could hear it through the
[ __ ] wall through the air conditioner
in the house is cranking in the evening
and I would go check on my mother out
cold I'll she just be at the edge of the
bed with her mouth open
not here knows that nothing and it was
[ __ ] loud that's how I feel about
candy L yeah the whole out that's all I
can do to keep waiting for you oh man
album cover done by Vargas you know the
famous playboy chick on the car yeah
it's just a drawing everything yeah dad
she's in the car I don't know if I have
kid I definitely have the first down
yeah but I don't have I don't think I
have can candy yeah I do yeah I do if I
know anything about myself that's fun I
always buy that for the home collection
I feel like they're in the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame yeah they made it yeah they
made it in and I feel like they're still
underrated it's bizarre to me like
they're they they have so many hit songs
they're like the new wave version of Tom
Petty
it's a [ __ ] they got a double disc of
hits an anthology like just all hits and
I said it before no pissed tracks when
you see them live there's no tracking
god I can go take a piss
there's no piss track cuz just um did
you see him I only saw him one time what
did you see him and I saw him on the
shake it up tour 1982 cal palace and
they destroyed they didn't say a word
nothing that came out played all the
hits I was like this is insane it was
like they were almost like aliens you
know you're like that's them whoa and
they sounded exact to the record which
is hard because they're they sound so
like the fidelity of them and everything
all the the layers of it the keyboards
and the guitar and all that the way it
sounds it could easily sound horrible
live a band like that you'd go and be
like oh it's a studio band
you know they can't do it live these
guys nailed it live they were fantastic
I think actually saw him twice I think I
saw him later on
two years later I bought Benjamin toys
one of his solo right and it was fine
yeah it was really high used to listen
to a while I was selling neon neon I had
an acura integra yeah a two-door white
one a 99th 1990 with the rims I got a
great deal on it when I got separated
I got [ __ ] tow trucks caught up Wow
score on that right
you're selling neon tubes the neon
actual [ __ ] I used to sell me on to
stores the first job I can handle yeah
after I got separated you know that
angle within your heart when you when
you go through a traumatic thing it's
hard to work you know how hard to focus
that could basically do is eat valium
and do stand-up yeah that's all you know
I had a girlfriend I just wanted to be
whatever in the daytime through the
younger than me and a friend of mine was
like listen man you gotta [ __ ] yeah I
love you to death
you could eat it whenever you want but
you got to do something with your life
and he will hold the neon shop it was a
glass and he goes I saw those neon
things I'm computing $50 open 1990 Oh
buddy was all looking for an open side
right right don't you that of 450
whatever you could get is yours
oh [ __ ] it started $1.99 yeah stolen
right now I bring a drill with me couple
screws yeah no matter but I would also
ask I would drop off a flier and if they
wanted more info than Danny would come
in and close them on the whole deal neon
and it was easy oh yeah dude was gold
what stricken WAP just pick an area and
just go to a strip mall and just drop
off call the sushi Dan strip mall go
across the street to the mall in there
hi how you doing just wanted to give you
this we're not interested okay yeah but
if I would pass out a hundred fly as I
get three to seven calls I would just
wake up go to Kinko's make 100 flies
that's wild neon signs open close and go
do you have neon signs that say open at
that time Costco didn't have them yet
yeah this was pre Costco I was doing
comedy and it was putting an extra star
lit like 200 like I sold a couple things
and I just kept it going every Monday
Tuesday Wednesday she had pass out 300
fly has himself five things just numbers
game
I love neon man that neon in the store
is half of what the store is it's so
wild when you're in there and they turn
those neons on whether seating people
and it's all the famous heads and the
names you know in the main room you got
the heads and then in the original room
the names and then as soon as the show
starts the neons come off and you know
the show is going it's it's it's such a
cool part of that the store and then the
neon I went to last time I was in Vegas
I went to the neon like graveyard you've
been there you go out it's all the
famous giant leftover neons from Vegas
old [ __ ] the Silverado and they're all
in there you could take a tour guys just
got them all on in this big yard like a
junkyard of neon it's [ __ ] amazing
that shit's cool people get married and
[ __ ] in there I got married at the Neon
Museum he was a really interesting guy
the guy sold me on for did he make them
or get him from somewhere no he did
everything himself he made him he had a
business his name was Danny fievel's I
met him I was working on a car wash I
was in the halfway house my wife was
pregnant
oh we had already had Jacqueline and I
met him at the car wash they pulled up
and I could tell by the music there were
listen tight are you guys Cuban they
like yeah and I'm like where you guys
from I like Miami and they go we live
exactly you left they lived in the same
apartment complex so I have to work
instead I go on a halfway house I signed
out to their house and I went over there
and a tour watch the Super Bowl we've
been friends ever since
Wow he told me in the shop with a
partner in his rank the home in Boulder
so I wanna I knew Ryan the funny thing
was I knew Ryan from 85 I dated my
ex-wife and her best friend was Ryan go
home so we all knew each other
so I went to work for them you know and
I would work out with Danny from time to
time me and Daniel around at night they
were very good to me they took me into
her home I was a little older than that
well I was like maybe 2 or 3 years older
than him and his wife but not together
no more but he had a right he had a
partner named Ryan go home and Ryan
could be a little difficult from time to
time
and I liked Ryan I always respected him
can I get that water for me there yeah I
respected Ryan
there was a weed shortage weed sure it's
every August yeah oh yeah yeah you're
waiting for the harvest to come full
moon the harvest you would go dry for a
few weeks and I remember we would drive
for like two weeks I mean this is what I
was going I didn't know I was about to
get separated I had already been in
prison I think I was out on at this time
I think I was still on Community
Corrections and I was smoked and they
weren't testing me no more they gave up
on testing me like this guy keeps
blowing up the machine no [ __ ] yeah I
put Drano in the piss all this [ __ ] yeah
so I was smoking and he had a deal with
me I was gonna give him like 800 bucks
and they were gonna drive up to hide a
home pick up a couple pounds and I had
dibs on but I had already sold fain
hundred yeah I wasn't a dip into that
just to hold me over you know whatever
the drive was to hide a home they
[ __ ] did it and they get back to
Boulder Ryan calls me what not the story
that I want to hear hello now and I'm
living in the Joey Diaz world like I'm
walking and painting myself I just
started comedy I really wanted to be a
comedian I didn't know where to start I
was two months into comedy
and I [ __ ] didn't want to go to work
no more they want to be a roof and
that's the main it I didn't want to be
married I just wanted my life to [ __ ]
end and now this [ __ ] kid who I gave
me my hard-earned dollars it's calling
me with some [ __ ] story oh [ __ ] right
at that time we had the condo but the
door and it was just like this there was
windows but that day the curtains were
open so I could see who was coming up
the stairs
so he calls back again he goes amen we
were talking before I didn't like it
telling a voice I said hey man
I gave you an allowance for something
and you're calling me with a [ __ ]
Chinese floor yeah I go sure you don't
love my toe and then he fired back well
we'll see when I get there what you told
is yeah so I hang up the phone and not
three minutes after that I hear him
coming up the stairs and by the time he
gets to the top thing I see him give me
the evil eye and I'm about five feet
from my kitchen and I had a knife rack
there yeah and I went like this with my
hand like hold on one second and right
in front of him I turned around I pulled
one of the knives out and I started
walking towards the door and he's
standing in front of me and when he sees
them coming towards him and thank God
this went down well he saw I was coming
he just [ __ ] ran down the stairs ran
to Danny's house and they both call me
and then it's like what's going on Ryan
just said you pulled a knife on him
he'll give me the announces there's no
problem lying on the phone hey man I was
just kidding with you didn't know I was
another plan that desperate Bronco don't
really know and then we got into it
again one time when I've got into comedy
I had an account like somebody went
there that took him a year to decide
what they wanted they were building a
restaurant the place was tremendous the
best restaurant still I've ever eaten at
my life Oh
due to the fact that they had a three
margarita look three margarita lemon
they asked you to leave
because what you were gonna go through
was gonna be hell
they made their margaritas with grain
alcohol oh [ __ ] so you're just wasted
and that lunch that would have many
margaritas for a dollar you would get a
[ __ ] up that the best bet was called
Rio Grande restaurant I'd be counting
there when they passed the fly that got
pulled me aside it was what it's just
about and just from my experience of
working with Danny I laid out what he
should do yes what do you suggest that I
go why don't you just put a tube three
tubes ground to highlight the room and
then put a sign that says margarita and
make it blink and tacos and so you know
every time I wasn't in the dinner I
would talk to the [ __ ] owner yeah and
he'd go I'm coming close I went with
design in this so I was doing comedy at
the time already and you know I was just
doing like part time one day this guy
called him put him like a twenty
thousand dollar water
whoa it was like three thousand dollars
in my pocket
yeah am I going to eat one day in the
[ __ ] neons up Oh badass I go one did
you get two nearly goes all we got an
install didn't Danny tell ya I don't
nobody [ __ ] told me yeah so I called
Danny Dennis I get he goes me and Ryan
are partners so we pay your commission
together I have you a check but Ryan
doesn't know if he wants to give you the
money I go the same Ryan I chase down
the stairs I'll bring two knives this
time called them up and he paid my money
and then we didn't do this Joey two
knives that's how I didn't [ __ ]
that's how my neon career ended but I
loved it
Danny really knew what Danny was right
now today I could look in behind Danny
Danny Feebles is one of the top three
neon people in the country you can make
anything that's cool he just the neon
business went down a little bit
yeah but his Cuban his family goes back
to 1920 in Cuba making Mia Wow it was a
family business in Cuba they were known
for neon fab
nyan company yeah yeah that blends
something he showed me all the stuff and
how I got involved with him was read
snort coke and he'd show me all the neon
magazines where they featured his work
now he would show me like the industry
standard magazines for me and they
probably don't have enough yeah right
but every month he would send in a
picture and he always always would put a
picture was working and he's established
as one of the best in the country hands
down for a long time they were flying
them all over the country
he just is little crazy so that
opportunity arose if I shoot a special
maybe I'll just do the backdrop will be
del Rey neon Del Rey like neon it's just
so cool it's funny because you mentioned
the original rule yeah
when Mitzi would feature would showcase
you she put the lights on purposely oh
yeah it was a different she leave the
lights on a little bit to let people
know as a showcase yeah that's how they
do it now he was a freaking pine nuts
yeah they still do that but if you are
on stage and one of those lights buzz
yeah
I don't give a [ __ ] of you with Jerry
Seinfeld bill Burt go Birds up there
show in from Joe's showcasing for Mitzi
shore yeah and the Kennison Lightwood
don't oh it does that she would go
scratch em off Sam don't like them Oh
your career if that [ __ ] neon buzz
you were done bad electricity any of
that neon buzz yeah you want stage show
whether it was that one of Louie you
know you're done she would say the room
didn't like you that's it the room once
the room didn't like you ah looks like
you better [ __ ] go showcase over at
the left back there
beyond and it's that's how [ __ ] what
I believe the me on there was a while
where the blue star cuz that tells you
you're done it was wired kind of weird
so instead even looking at the blue star
you could just hear it come on it goes
yeah you go the blue lights on never
even look at it isn't that wild
uh it's but I just remembered when you
were talking about neon that Missy sure
that's a great story
[ __ ] tremendous uh yeah that room
doesn't like you know how many nights I
would be hosting and she gonna show me
how I'm up and sit next to me you shoo
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo
and we sit next to me always going up oh
I don't like his name not tonight
whoa time should go oh what's that name
there Tyrone oh that's what I need more
spots is here
oh-ho-ho she would say little things
like that [ __ ] I don't need more
sponsors here oh look at this guy he's
handsome I'm gonna have in showcase
handsome but if that [ __ ] light if
that knee I'm buzzed oh I don't know how
many times she'd say to me oh the room
doesn't like him that's a crazy
that's a bumper sticker and then the
kind then I'd have to go downstairs
Oh comics would come up to me and go
what did she say she liked you yeah what
can I say they will come I was never bus
to come out balls now we're cuz that's I
couldn't I would never lie to the comic
I wouldn't say you know she says all
this guy's terrible yeah I wouldn't say
that to the comic I go she liked it
yep she really likes you you think she
patent that wouldn't see him anymore
they didn't get passed I get a lot of
emails from people and I'm just like 10
years in and they'll say can you look at
my set or listen to my music and tell me
what you think and it's just so
double-edged so you can't I don't do it
I don't do it if I don't judge this yeah
at all because it's another set no son
the thumbs up yeah but I will not watch
it it doesn't have like connection you
know many people connection you know
many people probably thought that you or
I were terrible or something when we
were started yet and it's not about that
it's about are you getting off on it are
you enjoying it are you doing it for you
that's that's what it's about
I'm not a critic critic or a teacher or
anything I just learn every day that I'm
on and that's what you got to do you got
to learn every day that you're on you're
not gonna be what am I gonna what am I
gonna say man that was terrible
that's not gonna help anybody or that
was great and you know it's just a tough
way you just got it doesn't matter what
I think or Joey thinks orally or anybody
it's just get out there and do it you
know it's it's bizarre harder that
people want you to tell them what do you
think of it it's just it doesn't matter
what I think
do you dig it I have never people send
me those it's embarrassing for me I
don't really like judging comments now
uh do you want me to look at your set
your temper that set for cold air yeah
or something I'll give it a shot
but if you've ever seen any of my 60
minutes since then that nothing to write
home about so how can I judge your an
hour yeah you know before the special
snow polish but can't started we spoke
about don't birth special oh wow it just
blew me the [ __ ] away
yeah I'm just blowing [ __ ] away I
thought that listen both of those
specials are sensational and I'm proud
to be a stand-up and abdomen represent
us you know obviously we're not at that
level to do that to have that
representation but both those specials
to chappal both on took the back the
old-school comedy one on one yeah
not to forget who the [ __ ] you are and
hula hoop wise I know who's writing
jokes to get a television show
and I know who's writing jokes to make
you laugh this is a big difference I
know who's writing jokes to please you
which I'm not either [ __ ] please you
I'm here to make you laugh now once you
see that being executed in a special you
dick gets hard yeah you know their
specials I watch and you're saying what
you want me to hear that's great I'm
happy that you took the time to write
but that's not what I mean oh when
you're catering yourself to what you
want to do that's not stand up
that's not stand up those two specials
let me know that stand up is still alive
and well in this country whether this
judgment whether there's you know
they're not PC culture PC culture is
never gonna ruin stand-up comic never
never not as long as bill burr keeps
doing what he's doing Chappelle does
what he does Rogan does what he does and
you as a comic continually do ya what
you need to do on stage you're not
censoring yourself those days are done
if you want to scroll this I got a lot
of [ __ ] going on but obviously as you
guys have noticed there's no TV show and
guess what after thinking about it and
that the constant thought I don't ever
want to [ __ ] do a TV show I don't ever
want them to scroll down my Twitter and
say my Twitter is contaminated you
understand me
yeah my twitter is unhireable yeah and
that's how I want it yeah that's exactly
how I want my Twitter I don't want to
get high now we're firing people because
of something they said in episode 148
I'm a podcast yeah well you better
listen to episode 99 a mother's [ __ ]
vodka
yeah well I'm torturing Lee and telling
Lena put his dick in his [ __ ]
neighbor's mouth while she's sleeping
you know I'm saying and so one of the
chances of me getting on any network
show anymore
as I go as a guest star and a co-star
absolutely yeah
don't hire me they won't know when I
come on TV somebody will send a video of
me saying chamber [ __ ] the one
[ __ ] acid with Lee or something yeah
you know you're putting on TV you know I
had an email once of a comic
sending me an email that [ __ ] you you're
over 50 is still doing mushrooms I just
thought about that yeah and I'm like
he's like you haven't changed you still
eat mushrooms I'm like yeah like yeah
what we said that's a kid thing yeah
this guy's a loser loser yeah he has a
bt out that tube I was [ __ ] four hey
what's up dude and he was accusing me
over you haven't changed
you still eat [ __ ] mushrooms Jesus
Christ I don't even think I was gonna be
50 yeah 50 yeah all right if I mean the
mushroom more [ __ ] power to you were
you the truck in judgment yeah we're
lucky you to judge me you know [ __ ]
crazy people I I just don't have I got
no time for any of that [ __ ] some use oh
yeah I got no time if they wanna [ __ ]
put on a memo that Dean Del Ray said
something wrong on stage guess what
happened you sell triple the tickets oh
yeah they made that side of my wife kids
career oh it's not people gonna go see
him here not only that but people cast
numbers will quadruple kiss yeah he
wouldn't want to be on silent live any
yeah they didn't [ __ ] favorite tweet
it they didn't afraid yeah it's like one
is to put the stickers on the records we
all wanted that one
you know profanity not good for families
and all that the PMRC
immediately you're like I'll take that
okay I'll take that record I gotta have
that you know I watched that documentary
again the one that Billy made about the
steroids you know and I go back to that
line that Manny Ramirez hit 20 home runs
he started working with the doctor in
Florida next year he hit 39 home runs
and the following season he tested
positive for steroids and got a 55 game
suspension about the rich it sounds
right yeah yeah was it when he was a
Dodger I'm sorry
tell me check it was one of those teams
I think it was a Boston then he became a
Dodger and they started booing about in
Dodger Stadium
yeah yeah but it's so weird when Alex
Rodriguez contact
same doctor Bosch yeah this guy when he
came up to Miami he said Alex Rodriguez
open the door and immediately said I
want the same stuff you gave Manny yeah
even though he tested positive
everything was a Dodger he was when he
was a DA for 55 games that's the [ __ ]
people want yeah you know when you're a
heroin addict you know what you want the
[ __ ] that killed oh yeah oh yeah you
know when the bad yeah the bad shits
going up in the street won't kill me now
my [ __ ] what's that Street in San
Francisco with Mission Street Mission
Street people would run down Africa
three people even better yeah we all
want to dabble in a danger danger we all
want it you know I've always loved the
dangerous [ __ ] the dangerous music the
dangerous comedy the dangerous cars
motorcycles always always never loved
comfort comfort is a killer comfort is a
killer man you know that a brother you
have kept me going over the years the
last couple years cuz were three is a
part of difference and I admire you what
you've been doing over the years no
matter that you go out there you go out
there you get my respect you know
because I know that you one of those
dudes that relentless though I could see
this in the 36 year olds heart I could
see this in the 38 year old guy you know
38 38 serious age yeah you gotta make a
[ __ ] move yeah but you're 53 you were
40-something when you start 44 44 when
you started comedy you had nothing to
lose you embraced it you already knew
the patience required for music you knew
that wasn't gonna happen overnight it
was sort of the same but not really oh
yeah totally this or this say yeah but
not really you still dealing what people
were trying to rob you yeah you're never
good enough they want this they want
that you're too old and you got a figure
I can you got to figure out how to avoid
the mind landmines yeah and you've done
it you know you've done a [ __ ] great
job with it so it's we
that sometimes on my [ __ ] here I am
on a six-year-old watching [ __ ] TV
and Dean's walking the streets in New
York
he's walking from the Springsteen
concert at the Garden to go to a 1:00
a.m. spot at the comedy [ __ ]
underground what's cellar Sullivan yeah
so in my boots they always get your
corns oh my god you got those [ __ ]
kamikaze boots on you walked and mouthed
them with your feet [ __ ] would feel like
I walk with sneakers in my [ __ ] yeah
more italics in there if I go to my
Chicago Airport this week I think was
the easiest flights I ever took in my
life oh man all four gates were right
next to baggage claim
oh never happens that oh my god
like I remember going through security
and I could see my gate from the
security right there that's the best
right you know yeah because we were
flying into Dallas yeah and that's not a
boy no airport when you go through
Daoist you better bring your roller
skate and you buy him your endurance up
just flew there was mirror and it's like
wow that one in Atlanta no one's big
Chicago's big so here man you gotta
being shaped in especially you gotta
connect them on American Airline oh and
they land you on sea and you're gonna
walk to H what the [ __ ] that's you see
that little black guy with a smile on
his face whistling three handicapped
people a little cart you get on this
stop 1 to 20 yeah you just remember in
the eighties you would walk into a bar
and take a bag of cocaine uh yeah do
this to the hot chicks like this the hot
chicks would be circled huddled around
with guys I think in real estate and you
come in and cut you to chase get out of
the way yeah yeah okay on the face and
wiggle that coke and next you know you
just walk down there with the broad it's
the same [ __ ] thing
oh yeah the guy with the cart man I jump
on that I jump I give him a twenty
intelligible go until the wheels fall
only white people would became scared
off yeah fake yeah this is this is not
stop it man no we're talking before the
podcast about
the vinyl incident last year oh yeah you
know I love Alex Jones I love Alex Jones
because I know him personally and I know
he says some crazy [ __ ] but every once
in a while he's you know 70% of what
Alex Jones says you agree with and then
from time to time he throws a wrench and
then you like Jesus Christ you were
doing so good yeah yeah I've been a fan
of Eddie trunks I don't know how long I
don't still a fan Eddie trunk you know
I've heard him [ __ ] say some
brilliant stuff on that trunk thing on
Monday and I watched him with Jimmy
Florentine and the other guy I'm the
heavy metal show yeah John Jameson fan
is I'm really a fan his since we started
the podcast because he does it solo he
takes calls he fends off savages he
fends off retards I mean he's got some
[ __ ] people Hall this week was good
yeah but there was a topic that came up
the last two weeks and the attack on the
internet and it was vinyl that he didn't
see the value of buying a CD for 10
bucks of playing 40 bucks for vinyl
Brian two days later somebody tweeted at
him that this was the first year that
vinyl since 1986 it's 2019 and since
1986 this is the first year that vinyl
has outsold CDs to [ __ ] right Wow they
took 14 plus 19
it's crazy something years for vinyl to
make a comeback now since 86 84 we
haven't been selling vinyl that means
right when do you think the down slope
the music started I mean I don't think
it started once
no because Motley Crue and Guns N'Roses
would dominate selling through the late
nineties sound bad yeah celibate yeah
even GNR I mean Alice in Chains and all
that the grunge selling big you know I
I saw Eddie he tweeted yesterday because
they the tool record the actual physical
CD of tool and the physical CD of Taylor
Swift has made the industry rethink
maybe we shouldn't get rid of the CD yet
because it's sold so many and he was
tootin is more like see I'm telling you
it's where it's at but I don't believe
in the CD I sold two thousand CDs five
years ago and four years ago sorry and I
was so happy I got rid of them because
once I saw they weren't going to be in
the cars anymore and on computers it's
when the industry decides to kill off a
a platform now once you don't have the
player sure they're gonna sell you know
Best Buy will have one player for years
and years I'm sure you can buy a VCR
somewhere right now I know you can but
they're not quality it's just a piece of
junk in the corner once the players are
out of the computer and the car I was
like this is a dead format and for me
and and there were just I got to get rid
of these because if I if I don't have a
player I always put it in a computer and
then let it play on to the speakers in
my house or in a car and if you don't
have it in the car it's like it's a
death to me of a product no player you
know I mean maybe maybe years from now
it turns around like vinyl did and
there's you know selling turntables all
over the place but if you don't have a
player for years what are you gonna do
with the stuff and and I just read today
Amazon has released a new platform with
this insane hive flak streaming that's
even bigger than title bigger files and
Neil Young was jumping on it like
finally the streaming is going to be
incredible and I think
that better and better the streaming
gets the all the products gonna be gone
because it gets down into people are
living in smaller places now because
they can't afford to live anywhere
especially in New York and all that you
can't have your thousand CDs or 2,000
records if you live in a studio
apartment
so once the streaming gets bigger and
bigger as the files it's I think all the
product might be gone I mean that's just
what I think what's funny because I
don't have a [ __ ] I love music yeah
but I don't have a CD in my car not
along this car and I've had this car for
two years no player right nope I don't
know if I have a plan yeah check-ins
yeah yeah that's what I have serious
yeah and I have you know grunge station
I got uh I got Ozzy's boneyard I got the
other one
I got studio 54 radio yeah I don't
really need twenty-two CDs in my car
anymore too much [ __ ] in your car like I
like listening to radio to break it up a
little bit yeah
when I'm at home I listen to old [ __ ]
and repetitive [ __ ] and I have like a
thing that's straight up on rotation on
YouTube it gets monotonous yeah yep and
it includes everything from Tony Bennett
Sinatra to Guns N'Roses
[ __ ] house and change to Audioslave
the other Soundgarden I mean I got every
bill there Zeppelin I was listened to
this morning I went to let there be Rock
say CDs all the one song and let there
be rock I just not bad boy boogie but
the one before overdose over dog man's I
go down yeah all that's on there so I
like when I get in the car to breath the
fresh air to get in the car listen to
something I haven't heard or push push
in the bush or whatever the [ __ ] that I
believe in that too because we get into
a rut even though I had thousands of
records I would always play like the
same hundred my god here it is I made
number the beast but when the Sirius XM
I feel is really
underrated I got on my phone now and man
it just the mystery of what's next is
great like ah yeah I've heard this in
years you know like I was sitting at
Studio 54 channel it is incredible
Alif incredible so just break out like
shake your booty shake shake hey
sometimes they play really bad disco of
course and it's hilarious but and you
giggle yeah I remember this [ __ ] [ __ ]
Cubans love this [ __ ] I'll murder why
they would damn this is terrible
yeah but I like to break it up myself so
do i I feel this this is what I feel I
think my generation we were so connected
to the album yeah if you were a musical
fan and you we were so connected to the
out you know I can't I've been coming in
here on Tuesdays at 4:00 and doing a
podcast with my daughter
oh yeah we tape it on the phone it's not
even a real podcast we have to fake
sponsors I give it 10 bucks part of the
process is after we do the podcast we
play records yeah I showed her how to
you know she likes crazy train she likes
war pigs you know but I see her face
lights up when she opens up the album I
break it down for her that musical
experience was something that we don't
get anymore
the album I think that I let an artist
be more the challenge an artist more a
little bit more like when they came to
me and they were like you know what
covered do you want I didn't have to say
don't like we paid some are that's
20,000 that sketch on me on that one
[ __ ] CD yeah you know I didn't want
that [ __ ] thing on my CD but I've no
choice right it's kind of jump out it's
gonna jump and I'm thinking back to back
and black yeah the whole argument with
they didn't want to release it cuz it
was black and almost never got released
yeah cuz the cover was black and they
CDs he fought for it but I like the
album cover because it made the artist
be creative towards the album it let you
open it up and see what liner notes he
put in there
Alaric's to the songs sometimes they
gave you a treat they actually took
pictures of the original page when they
wrote the lyrics on love that [ __ ] that
would give you it was more I'll never
forget when I did the longest yard and
they sent me the DVD of it and I opened
it up and it was just a [ __ ] thing
and I thought about how many [ __ ]
pictures I took on that [ __ ] set all
right how many hours the [ __ ]
pictures you know every day that was ten
[ __ ] photographers taking pictures
from everywhere on that sent how many
team pictures we [ __ ] took how many
pictures they took of us eating and
[ __ ] sitting there and cracking jokes
and laughing all of us on up on a bench
or at the hotel they were even thinking
think yeah you're like where the [ __ ] I
open up this [ __ ] CD and there's not
a [ __ ] thing yeah
not a [ __ ] thing in it not a thing in
them zero thought into they are zero
thought into the art but then I come
here and I pick up wish you were here
yeah and you look in there the guys on
fire on the Warner Brothers Laden you
know you could and even into the outdoor
Led Zeppelin gave different wine sing
they gave you the album cover should get
a dry sponge yeah and go through the
thing and it would turn different colors
they gave you something they gave you
that little extra connection cannot
attack lures kids that connection has
been lost yeah between the musician and
fan anymore tool went all out tool they
don't $40 CD it's out right now how does
it look it sounds great this is almost
rocking thang dude you open it up it's
got a booklet with all these photos in
the middle it's got a player a CD like a
a player inside there that you press it
it just plays like these electronic
loopy sounds and everything this thing
is it's a masterpiece of packaging a kit
they're gonna win a Grammy on the
packaging hands down because they do a
Grammy on packaging you never see it
it's the one they do like a week before
Grammy packaging Bubba
but this thing is on Josh Martin at
Stone at the store has two of them
because they sold out the first run and
they made another run unbelievable that
and that G in our box set they did last
year this [ __ ] monster another box
that opened up and had Duff showed me
and had secret passages right whoa we're
gonna san ECLA sand hole this [ __ ] in
there that stuff is amazing that's what
that's a shadow that's the [ __ ] you know
what people like me would pay for that
yep instead of a concert ticket yeah at
this price you're right
you know at this you know I would pay
for that momento momento it has all the
[ __ ] albums and posters and pictures
and masses that's kind of neat that's
what's been lost I think in Munich in
the last 30 years you know that little
last connection that we don't have I try
to keep it with comedy with comedy I
tried to keep that connection yeah
that's what's good about being a
comedian today then if we go on modern
what's the show on ABC Modern Family
yeah and we got on the most popular show
on TV for three years it never ends
after that the fans are the people that
don't talk to us now we could
communicate with them on Twitter
Facebook linking them whatever the [ __ ]
them yeah you know and to that's what's
different from us to say someone like
Jerry Seinfeld had it totally different
now we get on a show like right now
Gabriel could do those 10 episodes and
get on and talk to people about the show
on what they live tweet the Cheryl had
live tweet the show it's a different I
like that I didn't say I liked that I
got really enjoy I got the guitar picks
I bring to the shows to give people that
came out I got the Grateful Dean picks
I got stickers and and there everybody
goes how can i buy this I go now there
they're free when you come to a show I
just give people stuff they come up man
I love your podcast oh here's a pic big
wow they love that [ __ ]
and I know they love it because I love
that [ __ ] when I was young and I got a
pic at a concert Ted Nugent
pick out I'd [ __ ] be on the ground
digging through people's dirty sneakers
I got the pig had a couple pics I just
remember who picks they were oh I
thought I was really happy about I can't
remember who the [ __ ] I got some cars
picks actually I'm gonna tweet him up
today they say the cars on him and when
I saw him I was a me and this guy Eric
wet and can't we were the scavengers
drumstick went I was on the ground you
find money I pick some dudes [ __ ]
wallet you're like alright payday you
know like oh it's crazy it shows I got
pics
I got I got a pic collection I'll knock
you out man I love them they're all in
this word box you really for Chicago
next weekend oh I'm ready for sure gonna
be insane have you ever done that
theater before no no way
I can't wait I did with Rogen I almost
fell off the balcony oh [ __ ] what I'm
doing Cleveland the mall I can be Rogan
little Esther Oh somebody else did that
theater and it was oh man that theater
made me fall in love with copying it we
put a little asked up she blew it up
little Hester was there with red bam my
hands a couple of us but that theater
just that theater oh wait you go with
that oh I can't wait on it me you and
Kate Quigley yeah at the [ __ ] Chicago
Peeta I've done some amazing places with
you dared I was thinking about that
perhaps theater when we did that I had
the turntable backstage playing [ __ ]
records tricking express she's open show
that they know how to take care of you
that was great
and then we did that good one we did
another one before that - we didn't
Minnesota and you're walking yeah 120
yeah yeah yeah this one's gonna be great
we're doing San Fran what about when you
[ __ ] we wouldn't agree more from the
New York Comedy Festival and you came
downstairs and you go you gotta see this
oh yeah just through a table the fight
there was a fistfight right Bobby that's
crazy at Gotham full brawls
I'm ready weird
in San Fran and the second show got at
it right yeah my buddy just told me goes
oh I slept on the tickets they had to in
the back row I was like oh I don't know
and I went back to get them they're sold
out and then there was another show
added I go okay got like fifth row I got
scores a perfect weekend cuz it's night
before [ __ ] New Year's oh yeah I'm
coming back we're gonna not have a
podcast that week yeah I'm going skiing
with the fam skin I don't know if I'm
gonna show it is skin holo fun we get
Mego do it that's a YouTube video for
the four million head little local oh
yeah well uh Big Bear yeah well these
around
that's great skiing for two families
they have a house up there yeah i'ma
stay in San Fran and I'm gonna go see
dead and co2 nights when their plan
supposedly this is what I hear not
confirmed yet allegedly but I hear
they're going to be doing the brand-new
Golden State Warriors arena like 29th or
sorry 30 31 so I'm gonna stay and then
there's this giant do you mean what
Tower Records had those big record up
painted on the front they put up whoever
the records were they're big huge would
album covers front yeah one of my
favorite bands ever is the mother hips
and the thirty year band and they're
they're they're they're one of my
favorites underground kind of hippie
Neil Young badass man their first album
cover was mounted at our and San Fran
then they took it down they kept it and
it's been in storage ever since and the
guitar player is giving it to me so I'm
gonna rent a truck at u-haul and drive
it to the house here and have it in my
house this [ __ ] 30 year old big giant
wood album cover in my Hut I said I make
it a week and hang out with some friends
I'm gonna go check out a limbic guitars
they make handmade guitars for like the
Dead and every
and maybe do a podcast to them I'm gonna
make a weekend out of it you and I up
there eating Chinese food we're gonna
tear up somehow what's that place we
went we go forget them laugh let's open
up with the potato yeah yeah I go there
and with dual Colusa Fridays yeah then
Saturday night that I love that weekend
I love going out that weekend
Toby's alive that's crazy out of work
nobody really has to go to [ __ ] work
or nothing and people are festive people
are [ __ ] ready to go they've been in
the house it's [ __ ] Tuesday singing
Christmas carols arguing with people at
Best Buy yeah you know they're done
their [ __ ] job is done now they're
just it's a countdown to a new year
they're gonna lose weight they're gonna
wall it they're gonna take that pimple
off their forehead yeah you know we done
haven't in five days yeah yeah that's a
great date but go I'm excited for next
week I can't wait to eat a [ __ ] beef
sandwich oh I can't wait I use DVD
lion's mane s all from your lines gonna
be there to me this they hit meet it in
they said the whole team's coming by the
way hold on one second real quick yeah
let me do a quick little read here well
I got you here real quick I want to talk
to you people real quick the church
what's happen now one of our sponsors is
policy genius I don't know if you know
this but September's national life
insurance Awareness Month
did you know 40% of people don't have
insurance but getting life insurance
doesn't need to be difficult or
expensive right now prices are the
lowest they've been in 20 years
that's where policy genius comes in it's
the easy way to shop and compare prices
for insurance online just go to policy
genius.com
and minutes you compare quotes from top
insurers so you can get the right amount
of coverage at the best possible price
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home insurance auto
insurance and disability insurance
listen this is the way to go fast and
easy one thing about me is there's no
drama if you give me all these things in
one bundle that's
now I go now if you need life insurance
but haven't gotten around to it
September's the time to do it head to
policy genius.com right now head to
policy genius.com
today to compare quotes and apply in
minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now yeah look at your
phone right now
policy genius the way to buy life
insurance get it at policy genius.com
and tell them uncle Joey sent you right
my phone conversation hey I'm sorry
about that
I love policy genius I think they're a
great little product then yeah I need
some help
health care is what I need I'm actually
getting ready to sign up for the
California California health care we are
opening it back up in October the
signups imma get on that I got a whole
door fee I think I'm gonna be level one
this year I'm gonna fix this little
tooth this little tooth looks like a
baby tooth oh yeah yeah so I could see
they're gonna yank that out yeah they're
gonna yank that out every other you know
when I was a kid I went for the doctor
you had a cavity you did now you go to
the dentist and you need a root canal
immediately but the to bomb you know
it's going currently six months I'm
coming back then yeah yeah are you
taking me for 800 now and then it you
know you can't go to the dentist today
the death is used to be a simple thing
oh you went to the [ __ ] dentist the
dentist looked in yas'm mmm
you haven't been brushing lately you've
been eatin can do you have you not yes I
have okay you have four cavities we'll
get them going
you paid 280 or something you went home
now a little Chinese lady comes in the
back the dentist disappeared I'll be
back and awesome like a Filipina comes
and those people saw you anything excuse
me mr. Joe yeah yeah we want to talk to
you about what you need today you need
to listen listen listen this deep
cleaning
that's the scam is all away deep on I
know it's for six thousand Oh
but your insurance covers the 40% of
that and your deductible so your current
evolution would be 3,200 just having a
[ __ ] gambling yeah what do I need a
root canal
[ __ ] out boys don't bother me yeah well
see in six months says it's going
through I don't give a [ __ ] about
six-month delay what can we do today
listen brush it pull out the [ __ ]
plaque and let's walk and clean that's
it I tried to scare you every time they
go deep clean and you got deep plaque in
there and it gets into your heart valves
I'm like wait wait who came up with that
one five years ago they're like well
tell him it'll be heart attack
everybody's afraid of heart attack take
garlic and parsley Pablo Francisco
recipe please don't pick it I'll still
dick Pablo's made it this far garlic and
he takes three pills at night it takes
all the plaque all the [ __ ] my lugia
sticks everything out of your heart
valves oh and your [ __ ] and you're
walking around like Doris Day the next
day clicking your [ __ ] heels I jump
up and down and he told all the scams he
just ratted all the scams out well they
just taught it with that [ __ ] a couple
of years ago if you don't clean your
deep affection ardent that's what they
don't read about it yeah yeah deep
cleaning of the gums look I'm sure all
right whatever you got some plaque down
there and then put I mean everybody's
afraid of heart attack so they just like
will just juice it up a little more here
and then they charge it like 2,500 deep
competing they're like what and then all
you need to gargle with this a week this
is a $700 juice because you don't wanna
get an infection after we do the deep
cleaning and you're like and then you go
out and you're Europe dentist has the
brand new Lamborghini you're going oh
that's the [ __ ] deep cleans deep
cleans my ass fall for your Lamborghini
the green Lamborghini [ __ ] you know I
never experienced that before in Zombie
LA yeah they actually took me out of the
chair once and brought me to another
room to do the sale yeah that's how
they'd only take you out of the chair I
left I was like no [ __ ] no yeah I got
pictures they got all these photos look
at this guy right here he didn't get the
deep cleaning
oh man it's jaw rotted away he's got no
jar now you can't replace a jaw and
you're just going what the [ __ ] is this
no I got hearing aids oh yeah how are
they got hearing aids I told my wife I
said you know
I don't know if you people believe me
enough but I'm gonna tell you something
whenever I think of different situations
I always go back to the American family
I always go back to the American family
what would the regular American family
do if you know it's very tough to have a
family today both parents have to work
you know you're gonna flat it throws you
off for a [ __ ] month totally I've been
there I know the [ __ ] feeling you
know I went hearing aids or any other
type of eight you know you go they test
you then they sell you you know you're
sitting there and I told my wife last
night I go you know I'm talking I was a
[ __ ] criminal a felon the day I got
the booklet from sag thought I had
insurance like I nobody ever gave me
insurance I had insurance um one of the
unions I worked with like Hills Ryan
Jensen
but what are you talking about insurance
and then they made me fought this
paperwork and you get vested when you're
45 if you're in the Union 10 years and
you hit 45 you're on the movement
automatically vested and you're
guaranteed level 2 insurance oh man yeah
so my insurance is guaranteed I don't
have to you know everybody up to 10-year
mark
yeah like if you're 18 and you get into
sag yeah every year your insurance is
based on what you make right exactly so
the first bracket is 23 grand
yeah it's Pirtle now that's like 38 3
grand or something
and thus the get level one is like 38
grand I don't know exactly right my wife
said them um she goes you're always on
gym for two just from residuals thank
God I shot all that [ __ ] Natalie yeah
back when the money was made because
those are all residuals won't count
towards your sag earnings every year Wow
but I went to that thing it's nobody's
business what I pay for those
but I'll tell you I got [ __ ] in the
ass uh yeah but I'll tell you what I
can't imagine if I didn't have insurance
oh right so right away I think the
American family now they're only
guaranteed for three years
Wow you gotta buy a brand-new set every
[ __ ] three is that right yeah
the next time I go to Costco oh yeah
yeah you crazy
Costco last night yeah I was strangling
myself oh I would I would have shaved
off the bat but the doctor gives you
referral there
yeah well send it to Costco they'll send
it to the most expensive place right
taking your [ __ ] Johnny go BA and you
know you got to pay but on the way home
I told my wife I know think about the
American family oh that doesn't have
insurance and he has to pay for these
every three [ __ ] years yeah you know
think about that so my heart I'm all we
know the other day we were talking about
Yankee Stadium did you read that article
last week
uh-huh there was an article that came
out of New York Times about a guy who
got a noticed in the stadium from the
Yankee organization that prices were
gonna go up Oh
so he said he's had it they've raised
him forty percent forty in three years
so birdie there was I've been a favor
baseball game there's I've been a fan
since I was a kid he's gonna so I told
him I thought about it I talked to my
wife or whatever the story was the
contacted the New York Yankees and told
them he didn't want next year but he
wanted playoff tickets he didn't want to
playoff tickets
right but they based a playoff they're
all [ __ ] off the season tickets for
next year that's ball so if you don't
get the season tickets for next year the
price is double so he goes he went back
the next day they took 1,100 out of his
account for something and he wrote on
Twitter like he wrote this whole thing
the Yankees I've been a fan I love you
New York City's my heart but that's it
I'm done with you yeah he's never again
you got me I'm happy you got your 1110 a
$92 filing fee Oh something crazy don't
quote me on this Yeah right it was
something crazy and he wrote that that's
it that's the last time they'll never go
to Yankee Stadium again
and that he'll always go away to watch
ya easing their trip to st. Louis and
watch him or something
and right away I feel about the American
family yeah you know a New York ain't
bad enough you know many [ __ ] baseball
games I went through growing up oh it
breaks my heart it breaks my heart
compared to what a kid goes to it that
Shea Stadium I know it like the back of
my yeah seven dollar ticket $5.00 to my
mom dollar night dollar night that night
you know whatever today that that whole
thing like now when I do things I think
about the American family yeah me and we
always goof around about sushi Dan yeah
on sunset
they have sunset in a valley yeah yep
you know yeah I said happy hour from oh
my god we always I always we go happy oh
yeah man yeah I do the Taco Tuesdays man
everywhere in town last night I did it I
did Neal Brennan show at the Westside
Taco Tuesday at dollar 50 tacos
immediately give me four I eat like a
king for under ten dollars
you know like great talk what's the
place to Silverlake when you make the
turn onto from sunset way hop right by
the hmm yeah it's a Silver Lake they do
comedy there once in a while
oh yeah those are pickles of them yeah
the place on the right there yeah I've
done comedy that's oh yeah all right
Michael Tuesday but it's very obscure
yeah I have a ground beef with pickles
that before yeah tacos yeah talking it's
really different from what you're used
to
I'm trying but yes not bad if you got a
date you go down there
well I used to take me there Rocco
Tuesday we destroy any [ __ ] oh man I
mean I'm ever used to go to sizzler on
Mondays they would have the all you can
eat ribs beef ribs I think it was like
$9.99 or $10 and dude we'd go in there
and just rifle be for it the big ones is
home
Yeah right still there don't snot I
think it's still in looking up we I
think I just saw recently I remember one
time I was living with my girlfriend I
was next in scissor I mean it my biggest
movie roles in the beginning yeah it was
a chance Bob and Terry movie with a
bunch of stars that I forget the name of
it now women versus men women versus men
women versus men it was a one-day shoot
and they paid me nine hundred and thirty
six dollars I thought I was the
Clampetts
I thought I was yeah rich one of money
to check even came to the mail mm-hmm I
took my wife to sizzling we thought we
were [ __ ] in the Mafia Oh with the
peel me those [ __ ] Katrina shrimp
before Katrina yeah yeah yeah I think no
no no they took down sizzler cuz me and
my wife cried because we talked about
more on Western
I saw the one on Western racing yeah
throw up I was like well we ate there a
lot oh god it's gone huh it was yeah it
was next door to the Suzuki deal or the
commercial that's it
that's gone - that's gone - yeah yes
zukie I think is gone as far as
motorcycles I don't see those guys
anywhere I see Honda but I don't see
Suzuki anywhere I wonder if they're
still selling dirt bikes and [ __ ] knows
what they're doing this economy Chicago
next Friday yep we're ready to go I'm
ready got Kate Quigley yeah god [ __ ]
beandoor Izzie can't wait that's your
[ __ ] uncle Joey yeah before anything
real quick let me talk to you people
about something all right I gotta talk
to you about we spoke at the beginning
of the show listen man you're young
people will listen to this show a young
you know I'm 56 I'm a little piece of
[ __ ] you guys are young ah you've heard
us talk about hims and how they're
helping guys look their best if you
haven't yet it's time to see what
they're about
number one the problem is that 66% of
men start to lose their hair by age 35
and once you've noticed anything here it
could be too late I started losing my
about two years ago it's going quick but
my eyebrows are growing like a mother
difference so is that hair line slowly
starting to move backwards any bald
spots yes me listen I'm 56
my hair served its purpose yeah I'm
married I need [ __ ] hair for now in
fact I want to lose my hair like a
[ __ ] Zombo so I could scare people
make my wife feel bad for marrying me
boy you got old quick no yeah but you
mother you you little savages are young
so the best way to prevent more hair
loss is to do something but why bother
while you still have it it's time to get
a handle on those precious locks right I
asked you do you want a bald spot to pop
up on your hairline to receive or do you
want to do something about it first why
do guys turn to weird solutions like
spray paint and all that stuff when they
could turn to medicine and science
science hit for hims calm is a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for men listen to me
prescription solutions backed by science
hims is helping guys be the best version
of themselves with licensed physicians
and fda-approved products that help you
treat hair loss hims was created by a
guy who knows some men's health
conversations are easier online than
in-person normal offered in person
doctor visits or long pharmacy line for
hims connects you to the doctors online
will doctors which could save you hours
completely confidential and discreet you
answer a few questions doctor reviews it
and they determine it's right for you
they can prescribe you a medication to
treat hair loss that is shipped directly
to your door so do me a favor go to for
hims calm right now right right now I'm
gonna hook you up with a complete head
kit for five hours today five hours with
uncle Joey's here to help you guys out
listening a young you don't need to lose
yeah go to four hymns calm right now and
I'll get you started for five hours a
month while supplies last and subject to
doctor's approval see the website for
full
details and safety information listen to
me this could cost you hundreds if you
went to the doctor or a pharmacy
somewhere else go to for him calm slash
Joey that's for hims fo r hims calm
slash Joey the podcast is also brought
to you by my bookie dot AG it's Thursday
you got a game on tonight I don't know
who the [ __ ] that is but it's your
opportunity to make money you understand
me
football season is upon us you like
winning money you like betting sports
I'll tell you where you go if you gotta
put your money down my bookie dot AG
they got the NFL baseball MMA whatever
Chinese ping-pong three Japanese tattoo
contest they got it my book he's got it
they got better incentives and more
lines than any other sports book period
and this year they're running a super
contest you ready a hundred miles to
enter you pick five teams a week against
the spread and you rack up the points
first place is guaranteed $100,000 who's
better than you nobody
they just revamped the site and it's
looking tremendous I had on the video go
to my Instagram you'll see the video of
me placing the bets and how to do it
it's beautiful so go take a look if you
have it listen what we're doing this
weekend is we're gonna double your first
deposit you like Joey what are you
talking about you put in 500 my bookies
gonna match you file it off use promo
code Church to get a hundred percent
bonus on your initial deposit visit my
bookie dot AG today not tomorrow not
Saturday today
that's my bookie that AG and don't
forget to use promo code Church grab a
pen CH you are CH when creating your
account to claim your bonus listen you
play you win you get paid that's my
bookie dial AG next week we'll be back
with a video for you savages I want to
thank Dean Delray I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you guys do not forget
Chicago next Friday night and then
October I got Kansas City to the Uptown
Peter and the
I'm feeling [ __ ] Denver so get
ready Iraq we had to had a show in
Denver - Wow I love you savages stay
black have a great weekend thank you for
tuning in for the Church of what's
happened now thank you very much Dean
take this [ __ ] at me Olli
[Music]